why do you apply different standards for
a man and I would argue maybe because
I'm a man but I argue the standards you
have for men are a lot higher than the
standards you would have for a woman why
why do you have why do you apply
different standards depending on the
gender when arguably if you date both
it's actually about the person
um yeah like no that's a really good
point I think because arguably it's just
easier to be a man and so therefore
you're like well it's easy why is it why
is it easier to be a man one man I mean
the gender pay Gap just says it all okay
well but there's also a gap in like men
commit suicide War yeah men are dropping
out of colleges without toxic
masculinity that men can't speak about
so then so then why are we saying that
there's like a patriarchy when men have
it hard too
you just said women have it harder than
men but if women had it harder than men
like then why are men I didn't say they
had it harder I just said it was easier
to be a guy then but okay if it's easier
to be a guy then why do more men commit
suicide because they they feel because
of toxic masculinity which are
perpetrated by both men and women they
feel like they have to be macho and I
don't subscribe to that at all I'm very
much like um well it could it be
possible that men have a harder life
than women yeah of course it could be
possible of course it could be okay so
that would like contradict what you said
earlier well this is it it's not black
and white it's not right or wrong yeah
gray area maybe yeah so everything is
there's no like very solid so yeah
that's and even the whole
um Rule and exception there's all it's
not one size fits all it's really not
where there is that there are some men
who Thrive and succeed because they're a
man because life is easy therefore I'd
be like I would expect you okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna give you an example my
dad's the half top half a percentage of
earners okay he's the white man right
that but but here's the thing he worked
80 hours a week my whole life I didn't I
didn't get to see him yeah how is that
like the patriarchy when my dad put in
80 hours every week his whole life from
the time I was like a child right missed
a lot a lot of a lot of [ __ ] like he
earned that yeah and I'm never gonna say
that's like no the patriarchy anyway but
now now he's a white male CEO yeah right
so is is that the patriarchy or did
women not choose to do that well that's
the only way we could argue is the only
defense that you could have is if you
had a exact female replica to be like
she likely would not get where he is
that's the only way we could argue it
right so it doesn't want us to take away
from his efforts it doesn't take away so
then why do we why do we talk about it
at all if you can't if you have no no
idea why there's a pay Gap yeah but yeah
yeah like like it's is it possible that
it's the the industries that women pick
because if you if you like countries
that have more choice so if you go to
like the most egalitarian countries
there's more of a pay Gap rather than
less because women choose jobs with
people
and then use jobs with objects so like
my I'm I'm from a family of ten all the
boys are Engineers none of the girls are
Engineers like is it possible it's a
biological difference rather than a
patriarchy yeah no I think I think well
I think the pay Gap is more like within
so I don't know if you saw on
International women's day they had a bot
that literally showed you the pay Gap
within organizations so obviously women
will tend to go for things like being a
nurse being a teacher yeah they pay a
lot less than being financed correct yes
yes but the pay gut then exists in so a
lot of things where there's a lot of
male actors who will be like I will not
uh sign on to this contract unless I
know my female counterparts are being
paid the same and so I think the pay Gap
then comes and well it's also the truth
it's also the trait like
disagreeableness so as women like we're
naturally more agreeable 100 so so we're
I'm more I'm terrible at negotiating I
just want to make everyone happy and I
just want to be like yeah I'll do
whatever for nothing and
um and but that's like men are more just
disagreeable if you look at the
agreeability scale does that make sense
yeah yeah so again like why do we just
assume patriarchy when you don't know if
it's because of different personality
traits and gender differences no and
gender they are so real so in my studies
um it showed that so men are more likely
to go for so let's say there's a job and
a woman is more likely to look at a job
specification and go oh but she's more
likely to say no to herself and she's
more likely to go
um or I don't know if I'm good enough
yeah or as a man is more likely to
actually inflate their ability and be
like I'm gonna go for that and it
actually reflects in relationships where
a man is more likely to actually shoot
above and be like yeah yeah I can I can
yes so it's a reason we see a lot of um
less attractive men with more attractive
women the women are more likely to be
like look I spent a lot of my life being
like I'm a four out of 10. I'm I'm
probably about seven but I spent a lot
of my life dating men and people would
be like Amy that guy is not in your
league like why do you not and they're
like they're definitely like you know
out like you're out of their league and
it's actually yeah there's a real gender
difference and
is that biological is it social
right there that's because men and men
and women value different things man
value looks more women don't value looks
as much they value things like social
status like a blue check mark a blue and
this is yeah I've dated a guy with a
blue check mark right like we like
social status yeah like we'd be lying if
we said we didn't care or whatever it is
like it's it could be height right it
could be like it could be you know maybe
he's not as good looking facially but
he's he makes money yeah or he makes
money yeah right and so that's why we
see there's a gap in that yeah yeah we
don't we don't scream patriarchy for
like men yeah yeah like but then we
don't know that's it we don't know is it
because of uh so you've got the
biopsychosocial approach
um and that's which is what I tend to um
subscribe to because that's it it's not
easy to be like oh it's just biology or
it's just sociology or it's just your
personal my question is like yeah like I
just don't even understand like in this
day and age how we are fighting the
patriarchy like what more can they do I
can do any job I want
like nothing has ever stopped me from
doing anything yeah so like I don't even
know like I don't even know what I need
feminism for now okay I can't think of
one thing
um I have a question going back to what
you said and I think it's fun but I
wanna
give you a scenario so you said
originally that the reason you arguably
apply a higher standard to men is
because you felt life was easier for
them so it's easy you should expect more
from them
or they have advanced is
right let more so than women right so my
question then
is would you apply a higher standard to
a white woman
over for example a black male
you would
really
so you would expect the white women to
earn a certain amount to be taller than
you
to make you feel protected and to be
able to provide for you more so than if
you were getting to know blackmail
I well then it's the intersection
between race and gender but that's it as
a westernized white woman I'm well aware
of my privilege
um and it's like I know that
like oh it depends on well that's it it
depends on
oh it's tough because I'll be I'll be
honest like I think women just always
apply a higher standard to men than
women because they're men regardless of
what race they are so say like we go for
a job interview oh wait wait you're not
in binary me and him yeah who are you
dating
[Applause]
who are you picking yeah he probably
makes more money than me yeah but then
but then but then being a female I'd
probably be like is money my most
important or is it emotional connection
and how funny you are like it would
depend on what as a woman I think I
would oh I don't know
that's it would would well as a woman
that doesn't necessarily want kids
anytime soon and it's quite financially
independent I probably wouldn't be like
money probably wouldn't be my priority
so then I'd be like Well Physical
attractive would come into it but then
funny okay
no but it's really hard
to be like is it just money is it
protection because I'm also quite
Scrappy so I can hold my own as well I
don't want a man to protect me because
I'll fight do you think you could fight
me